true wealth cannot be created working
it can only be created investing elon
musk is completely invested he has no cash
and no houses because elon knows the money
game he knows the whole thing's a big scheme
there's real estate fun i'm doing and she's
like why are you doing this for people i said
i want to help the little guy become a big guy
all right believe nation back again long time
friend of the channel the one and only mr grant
cardone welcome back man how you doing uh always
good to be with you buddy merry christmas early
happy hanukkah um that holiday season time is
here that makes people more grateful and i think
it's a good time of the year for people to
reflect on family and accomplishments and
potential appreciate you man well today i'm i'm
super excited because we're talking investments
and i you know i've consumed your content for
years probably more than most people i love the
entrepreneurship and the sales and the motivation
but my favorite video of yours that i've seen in
the past year was when you you rolled up on your
office come out of your car uh start walking into
the whiteboard and you're saying hey if you're a
ballplayer if you're a rapper if you play second
base let me show you how to invest in real life
and then you go to the white board and you break
the whole thing down like ah mind blown i love
i love this video and i think a lot of times you
don't get enough credit because they might see
the glitz and the in the flair and the jets and
all that but not enough credit for how smart
you are with actually creating sophisticated
structures to invest and avoid taxes yeah
well thank you i appreciate you saying that
you know the the problem with youtube and and
instagram is is if you don't if i don't do some
of that stuff uh you know it's just hard to get
through man like i'm competing with you know
this week it's omnicron and and um i think you
know you know the world's crazy dude like it's
a loud noisy crazy world with a lot of problems
in it and and even if you have a great product
and you're you know this like even if you have
a great product great training great education
information you know the best the best guy or
gal doesn't always win and typically it's the
loudest you know and it's where in the beginning
you got to be if you don't have any money like
if you don't have a big budget if i don't have a
coca-cola budget i can't you know i can't compete
with the apples and the googles and the facebooks
and the metaverse and the nft world now that
everything everybody's going to go digital now
right so it's like how do i get attention and most
of the time evan i don't even know what i'm doing
i'm just trying to do it but that particular video
we were targeting uh the artist uh the athlete
the rapper and and it worked by the way okay like
i'll give you a little i'll give you a little
success story tiffany haddish came to my house
two sundays ago she saw that video
she became a fan because of it and
i talked to her about this this real estate fund
i'm doing and she's like why are you doing this
for people i said i want to help the little guy
become a big guy because what's happening right
now in the investment community is the big guys
just keep getting bigger and bigger that's obvious
to everybody on both sides like the big the
wealthy just keep getting wealthier and wealthier
and it's because of the asset investment
opportunities they have available to them
and ball players and rappers don't get them
either rich people do not get access to the
kind of opportunities that that i'm talking about
today it's only wealthy wealthy institutions and
i just discovered this in the last five
years as i was attempting to do to create
my own wealth for myself and my family i started
discovering that this whole thing was on lockdown
that that you got to be super super super
connected to ever get access to an ipo
uh insider real insider information about
the direction of something or the economy
or so anyway you've kind of become the underdog
again when you're going up against goldman sachs
and bank of america and like the giant financial
institutions of the world and people might look
at you say he's got it all figured out he's
like no no like grant's the underdog trying
to take on these giant corporations again
one thousand percent and and then and you
know the the system set up not to have this
like we we had there's an accredited fund
what i did was i started building i started buying
real estate years ago as you know okay i ended up
with uh i don't know about 4 000 apartments that
that i personally own 4 000 apartments the rents
about you know 2 000 bucks a month one day i
looked up i'm like damn dude i just got i'm rich
like like this is not this isn't my other
business this isn't the seminar business
the event business the webinar business the book
business this is a business that can go it will
go on and on and on forever without me this is why
so many people are in real estate because the the
generational real estate can be created for you
know 30 years after i'm dead 60 years after i'm
dead that doesn't i don't need to be there so we
started raising money about maybe three years ago
and started letting evan carmichael's uh
people that speak on my stages our business
partners our customers invest with me because
people started to hear about what i was doing
but it was just really high net worth
individuals 200 grand 400 grand 500 grand
and money just poured in dude i couldn't believe
how how fast money came in we raised 700 million
dollars with no ad budget in three years that
bought two billion dollars worth of real estate
we've been making distributions every month to
those investors this this year we we distributed
35 million dollars in this year so i've made
more distributions that than most people
ever making money okay and we're sending this
back to our investors well what happened was
uh what the more i started telling people
about that the more 98 of my audience which is
non-accredited the 98 of america is not accredited
they would not be able to invest in these funds
and i started kind of feeling bad about it
because i'm like wait a minute the the very
people i was non-accredited before i was
accredited everybody's born non-accredited
everybody starts as a little guy right so i said
guys let's i want to start a non-accredited fund
for the everyday person i want to be
able to put a thousand bucks in a deal
everybody told me do not do it it's going to be
too costly it's too expensive it's going to bring
lawsuits you're going to have problems little
guy's gonna be up i said hey hey listen man
i want to do the deal i already thought
through all that stuff do the deal okay
so then they started doing the paperwork to
create a fund for the non-accredited it took
nine months to get it approved and 350 000 and
i probably had 20 people working on it full-time
now now it's really important for everybody to
hear about this because this is an education on
our financial system to get an accredited
fund approved it took me nine minutes
and nine grand in nine minutes boom i
had a stamp saying go raise money to get
non-accredited to help the little guy out okay
everybody listen to this that if you're watching
to help the little guy out it took nine months 350
000 and 20 people working on it almost full time
we just got approved in 50 states and by the sec
federally to raise money from the little guy so i
started looking in i started looking at why is it
taking so long oh they want to protect the little
guy i'm like okay all right but why does it take
why do what protect them from what dude i'm buying
a piece of real estate that will always you can't
lose money in these deals virtually cannot lose
money you can lose money in the stock market uh
bonds gambling loans all that you can lose money
like there's almost no way to lose money in
that deal because it's cash flowing when we buy
so what are you guys really up to and then
i started realizing the sec was put in place
by wall street it was funded by wall street to
regulate and protect the little guy but the very
people that put them in place okay they can afford
350 000 to create their funds they they can afford
30 million you know and and so and what they did
was they have the exp it's so expensive to do
it nobody does it because a little guy typically
is not going to invest that kind of money to let
a little guy invest a thousand bucks so i i
you know we took it on we did it uh we had uh
we had uh uh 27 000 people registered in the first
three days to put a thousand dollars or more in
that piece of real estate right behind me i think
it's going to be super successful i think it's
going to be really good for them i know it's going
to be good for them i think it's going to be good
for me also because it changes the narrative about
about grant cardone i'm not i'm not just selling a
book now i'm basically somebody's not they're not
really buying anything for me they're investing
with me as a partner and you know now now we're
both on the same page it's not it's not a consumer
a sale it's not an exchange of a product for money
you know we're kind of joined at the hip now well
before with your books or videos or training
they still have to go off and do something
or now they don't have to do anything you're
going to do the work all you got to do is sign
the document i've already picked the asset
and by the way this has never been done
before what i am doing has never been done
in this country at this level trophy asset
the these are institutional quality
assets the you've mentioned two groups
that we got deals from uh this month that we're
closing on they were competing with me for the
deals like they don't even know what i'm doing
here like i'm nobody to these people these are
trillion dollar companies not billion dollar
companies and not not an exaggeration these are
trillion dollar companies that they have their
biggest problem is money i didn't know all this
like this is all a new discovery for me so i'm all
lit up about this whole thing about this taking
on this giant because they're not going to call
evan carmichael's family and say hey blackstone's
not going to call you and say evan we got this
great deal it's a quarter of a billion dollars
and your family can invest uh 50 grand in
it ain't gonna happen you're never gonna
get the call in your lifetime they're gonna
call their buddies that sit on other boards
the wealthy you're calling the wealthy make it
more wealth and the little guy gets left out
so i'm i'm really proud that we're doing this
i'm excited about it the the people that are
investing with me are excited um so i appreciate
you giving it some attention um it reminds me of
on undercover billionaire when you were trying
to raise money in pueblo to get the real estate
deal done and you had to be careful of like how
much you could let on and like how does this guy
know so much about real estate you know and and
so the pitch on the whiteboard um it's great i
mean it just we don't get to see that often the
smarts you know like how the deals are structured
and why it's so important but and i love that
it's starting to come out more in your content
what are your thoughts on elon musk and jeff bezos
barely paying taxes and and warren buffett being
in a higher tax bracket than his secretary like
how are these ultra rich guys basically avoiding
paying taxes because they don't earn income so
look elon does not earn income warren doesn't earn
income and neither does jeff so this is the game
right we're all taught get a good job earn and get
get a good you know go to school get take on
debt get a good job improve yourself at the
job so then you'll get more money but the more the
more earned income you get the more the more taxes
you pay so the goal is the goal should be for
everybody i've been studying money for 25 years
i've talked about money for a long time got a
lot of haters because i talk about it so much
but the goal is not to have earned income the goal
for everybody should be to have passive income
that you don't earn that you don't trade time for
so like in my in my regular business in my you
know if i go speak to a group i traded time for
money i earned income half of that's going to go
to the tax ban the half that i end up with i take
and i put in that piece of real estate right there
with that piece of real estate comes write-offs
deductions depreciation and passive income
the goal you see none of us were taught about
wealth we were taught about how to earn income
and earning income is you know those people
that earn income uh pay taxes so my goal is to
get to zero income earned income and have as much
passive income as possible the only way to create
real wealth is to invest is not to work hard this
is why warren says i should pay more taxes it's
it's a shame that my secretary pays more
than i do we should raise taxes on the
rich the reason warren says that is number one
to win fans number two he it don't matter if
you change the tax code on warren because he's
not gonna pay income anyway he's not gonna pay
income taxes because he don't have no income
okay he earned 500 million dollars last year
uh in dividends passive income on his coca-cola
investment the guy that runs coca-cola made 50
million check this out the ceo of coca-cola earned
50 million last year and paid uh 63 percent out in
taxes so he ends up with like 30 million warren
gets paid 500 million dollars the point of the
story is you know you don't want earned income now
in the beginning you've got to have earned income
the baseball player has to have earned income
it could be 2 million 5 million 25 million but
uncle sam's going to take most of it we're not
taught how to invest you cannot create wealth
true wealth cannot be created working it can only
be created investing and investing is actually the
easiest thing somebody can do so it's a crazy
kind of loop uh we just have not been taught
to use money correctly instead we save money
now keep this in mind okay and then i love doing
this with you because it because to me this is my
real purpose is to re-educate people about money
we're not financially illiterate we
we've been financially uh programmed
to make mistakes the institutions and the
system that taught us how to use money benefit
they are the beneficiaries of how we don't use
money okay make money trade time for money go
to the bank and drop it off and save that only
benefits wells fargo bank of america citibank
the whole list see it goes it goes to community
it goes credit unions and community banks then
it goes wells fargo bank of america citibank
then it goes to goldman jp morgan and then
it goes to the real players and it ain't
jeff bezos or elon musk or warren buffett
at the top of the freaking food chain or
companies like blackstone okay and vanguard
these are these are 10 trillion dollar companies
they run planet earth they're the richest those
two groups right there are the richest two groups
on planet earth today they literally have their
hands in everything everything this big they they
control what's on stock on the stock market who
gets a loan who doesn't get a loan so when i go
buy an asset like that by the way their biggest
problem all these big giants have problems and
their problems is money they have so much money
and this money is ain't [ __ ] by the way
this is not new money new names old money wait
we're very very old and and they need real estate
they have to consume real estate because it's real
and it produces dividends to their investors and
the people that hold their paper you know it's a
casino man it's a giant freaking vegas casino and
in in a casino just like when you walk into steve
wynn's hotel there's there's blackjack and there's
there's the the pull bars you know 25 cents to
25 the roulette wheels the back rat there's all
these game tables same thing with the stock market
and and and and so everybody's gambling and
these handful of companies benefit from you guys
gambling and then they scare you about the
gambling so they say save your money plan
for a rainy day give your money to us and we'll
manage it because you don't know what you're doing
and what i'm doing is i'm intercepting this
thing actually barack obama passed a law called
the jobs act in 2012 that for the first time in
history allowed a guy like me to even raise money
2016 that law was amended to allow me to raise
money from non-accredited uh the little guy
so when we open this that's 230 million that's
the actual piece of real estate we're raising
money for right now i bought it with my money i
signed the debt it's 230 million bucks i sign a
loan for 160 and i write a check for 70 million
i do that to give my to give my followers the
audience anybody that wants to invest with
me confidence that i believe in that deal
if no one invests i own the deal if people
come back and invest we're all partners
so uh people can invest a thousand bucks five
thousand bucks ten thousand bucks twenty thousand
it's a long term investment you are illiquid
you can't call me up three months from now
i need my money back that's not how this deal
works see wall street promises you liquidity
notice here's a little thing man stay liquid you
were told that when you were growing up you need
some cash you need an emergency account right keep
cash around you need a little cash and then what
happened is once they convinced everybody to
keep cash they quit paying you anything on it
and so if you look at if you look at elon musk
elon musk is completely invested he has no cash
and no houses because elon knows the money
game he knows the whole thing's a big scam
and that's why he said the other day he's like
you guys seem to misunderstand that i don't pay
taxes because i don't earn income and
the only way for me to pay taxes if you
remember the tweet last week the only way
for me to pay taxes is to sell my stock
you guys decide should i and then he sold a
little bit why because he needs some money
so the game's on lockdown man and i'm trying to
i'm gonna my my legacy project will be to and i'm
courageous enough and crazy enough to do this
i'm gonna take on these big giants one of the
groups that i mentioned earlier was trying to buy
that deal and because they're so big they're slow
and i'm small and nimble so i can move
faster and that's how i got that deal once
once we got the deal under contract they
called and said we would like to give you
the 70 million in equity and we'll keep you in
the deal that's how bad they wanted this asset
and they they didn't want me to
go to my public and raise the
money they want me to come to them for the money
the other thing you seem to be on a
crusade on is re-educating people on
debt that most people think debt is bad
because they're taking on the wrong debt
and you're out here saying no no no
debt is good all the rich people use
debt you have to learn how to use debt
why are people's views on debt so wrong
well because you know look a a
a us dollar is basically debt
there's nothing to support it or back it up okay
the manufacturing of paper by itself is debt
cash is debt okay so um you know again we've
been programmed cash is taxed debt is not
so if if we would quit studying our uncle the
millionaire the millionaire next door which
you know was one of the most inspirational
books i've read in my entire life was that book
it inspired me to not be a millionaire i read that
book i'm like i ain't gonna be that guy for sure
okay i got to go buy a used truck i got to go
negotiate buy low sell that's not how wealthy
people operate they do not worry about whether
they don't even buy cars they're like have a
look have a limo pick me up so so the thing
on debt i mean the thing on learning is first
we should be studying wealthy people wealthy
people maybe even not people but institutions
very very few people actually
understand the money game
and it's not the people on cnbc by the way those
are pundits reporting the news that know very
little about money and i and i know that to be
true because they don't have any real wealth
okay they have earned income so the debt game
the debt game goes like this all right um
apple computer borrowed uh two weeks
ago borrowed uh 90 90 billion dollars
from japan and they had 140 billion on hand
now why would they borrow 90 billion when they
had it in the bank because the 90 billion comes
with tax write-offs and using cash does
not so they get the best of both worlds
they keep their cash on their accounts
makes them look good to their investors
and they borrow money from japan at almost nothing
for instance we're boring money on that project
right there at 2.8 percent i think maybe two point
yeah two point eight three percent five years the
thing's gonna the thing's gonna earn five percent
the first year so i'm earning five percent
on 2.8 money and that in that that that
difference is how people get create super wealth
debt is all deductible to infinity by the
way there is no limitation on how much debt
interest i can write off my taxes so like last
year i'll just give you an insight um i oh today
i don't i we have about four billion dollars
worth of real estate i owe um 2.2 billion dollars
in debt i want more debt i don't want less uh if
the world goes to hell by the way i get helped out
because now now it's just too big to to to just
you know they they want to help so we weren't
taught this i didn't even know this until 2008 i
discovered this in 2008 i owed 50 million dollars
to the banks and the banks pay up pay up how am
i why you calling me i've never even been late
because we know you have money i had money
in an account cash see when you have cash
people will sue you and banks will come get your
assets when you have debt they leave you alone
can't you can't get uh blood from
attorney or whatever that saying is
okay so let me just tell you what i paid in in
interest last year you can write off up to 750 000
worth of interest on a home and
then you can't write it off anymore
i wrote off 88 million dollars in interest
last year no limitation that number could be
800 million 8 billion 80 billion it's all tax
deductible so we need to reprogram how we think
about debt okay and and also how we think about
cash you can also write off the depreciation right
i mean right at the beginning well this building
right here good good point like this building
you know if i save cash it goes down in
value but i don't get to write that off
everybody knows cash is going down in value i
think it's lost 90 percent of its value since
warren buffett was was uh born 90 of his value
90 pennies out of every dollar that building
right there we will write all i'll own it for
20 days in december we'll close december 10th
and i'm gonna write off on that deal probably
28 million dollars in the month of december
my jet i just bought a brand new plane
54 million dollar plane i wrote off the
entire 54 million dollars in the month
of december took one business trip
that's why coca-cola buys planes
that's why pfizer has helicopters
so that's why we all need to figure out
okay hey what's really going on here
and and for all you guys out there you're
on the come up right you're trying to figure
out okay i'm making 30 40 000 bucks a year okay
first thing you got to do is get your income up
second thing you do once you get your income up
do not spend earned income above what you need
invest all of it so let's say let's pretend
somebody could live on 50 000 bucks a year
and they go from 50 to 80. don't spend the 30
live on the 50 make more money take the 30 and
and put it in a real asset that has depreciation
and debt you go next year you go from 50 to 100
you make more money take the whole 50 don't change
your standard of living don't go buy watches and
okay don't go don't go improve the quality of
your life improve the quality of your investments
take the entire 50 all of it okay i dare it i
dare you guys to have the courage to do this
at the end of every year i get rid of all
my extra cash and i put it into an asset
i walk into january first every year
with zero money just like i did in puebla
so so when when i did undercover a billionaire
they they said when i was flying into pueblo
they said what's the first thing you're gonna
do i said first thing i'm gonna do is go to the
bank and drop off this hundred dollars and
they're like well why are you going to get
rid of the 100 you're going to need i'm like
i'm never going to spend that hundred dollars
they didn't show this in the show
but i never spent that hundred
never touched it because i always act like i have
nothing and in most cases i don't because i take
my cash which we know is going down in value and
i put it into a building i get rid of it i don't
want to touch it nobody's calling me for cash
because everybody knows i've made it public i
don't have any cash you want to sue me you're
going to have to break that damn building down
like it's going it's you got to pull teeth
to get money for me because all of it's in a
building or a partnership where it's protected and
that's what those rich guys are doing to prevent
their uh their themselves and their families and
their future estates from being taxed so someone
investing cardone capital and we'll link that up
in the description below guys you can go check
that out and say they get 10k in distributions
from you for the year yeah how is that taxed
let's say we can walk through some numbers 10k in
additional income from earned income versus 10k
cardone capital distributions what's my
difference in paying taxes on it so so
if you earn ten thousand dollars you're going to
pay in the state of new york you're going to pay
uh 6 300 bucks in taxes let's say you're making
100 grand a year you're going to be taxed as
earned income is at the highest rate on on
passive income that number should be uh below 20
and if you're an accredited investor and
can take advantage of the depreciation
which most people can by the way you're not going
to pay any taxes on that ten thousand dollars so
a five percent let's say let's say you put 200
grand in and it paid five percent return it's
passive income you did not work on the project
passive means you didn't touch that project you
didn't buy it look for it hunt it down manage
it a lot of people are investing in real estate
they think they're getting passive income you're
actually going to get taxed later as earned income
okay when you're buying a building yourself and
managing it that's earned income not passive
income so we have third party management so i
don't i never touch those buildings i buy them
and then we have a third party that
manages them and all the investors
get passed through passive income which
should be um treated by your accountant as
with a k i'll send a k1 to you at the end of
the year that says hey we paid you 10 000 but
you're allowed 30 000 in write-offs i'm just
giving you an example it's not an exact example
so that can actually offset against your other
income as well so that's why so many people use
real estate they use real estate so many people
use real estate number one because it's real
protects against inflation it cash flows but the
other reason is because it starts it becomes a
a tax haven without having to go to the caymans
yeah i think i think that's the biggest thing
people are missing because they think of passive
income just as i don't have to work and i get
money coming in which it is but the tremendous
tax savings on top of it yeah you can even carry
forward the future years is crazy yeah and you
know there's a lot of a lot of misunderstanding
about this there's a lot of e-commerce guys that
talk about i get passive income i'm like no bro
you don't if you ran an ad that's not passive
income passive income is basically by definition
it's uh it's real estate royalty income copyright
like it's something you did one time and then you
sold it to somebody and then they pay you nfts are
going to be by the way a passive income provider
if it works out if it doesn't blow up
all over the place but it it's if i
sell a piece of art today and they trade it
later and i get paid that's passive income
but me having to go out do a piece of art sell
the piece of part that's active income the second
third fourth fifth time it would sell that would
be passive and it should be treated as passive
what do you think is more likely grant
cardone gets his own show on cnbc
grant cardone runs for senate or governor
or grant cardone launches his nft line
um the most likely probably one two three order
them order them yeah uh order order well i do
have an interest in politics i i'll tell you
i'll tell you a little behind the scene thing
my goal my ultimate goal with this is to put i
want 20 million people to invest money with me
so we have an email database of about 3 million
people right now 13 million people online um
we're definitely i'm definitely getting known in
the world right now okay so i'm starting to break
through and um so the goal the internal goal is
i want 20 million people to invest 10 000 with me
that'll be 200 billion dollars in cash
that's a war chest now 200 billion dollars in cash
will buy one trillion dollars worth of real estate
see the beautiful thing about you know the
ability to crowdfund from the regular everyday guy
is when you send me a check and then i start
sending you money back me and you together we're
we're we're buddy you're you're my guy i'm your
guy we're we're we're now in a business together
somebody says something bad about me you're gonna
be like hey knock it off man that guy pays me
in my family every month now imagine if i wait
and do this for 10 years and i have 20 million
people that i've been paying for the last 10 years
every month and let's say i want to run for some
office you know and you're in that booth saying
you know grant man i you know i don't really
i don't really like his political abuse but
god damn it he's been paying me every month
so so we're going senate
or congress and which party
yeah well i'll go with the party that i can
win with okay if i ever did that right but but
i mean the whole political thing i would just
do it because i'm a disrupter i like a fight
you know i like i've been i've been the little the
underdog bullied ever since i was in high school
i was looking at some high school books the other
day somebody showed him tell me i'm like yeah bruh
mike mike ormandal that beat the armada or
whatever his name was it beat me up i'm like yeah
but i bet he's seen what i'm doing now you know
i have this little chip on my shoulder right so
i like those fights and i also like seeing
problems and trying to do something about it
so if you could wave your magic grant cardone
wand and and change one law what would it be
well right now uh i would change man there'd
be a lot of my change uh one the first one i
would be i would do is i would i would
change the 12 year 12 years of school
and and and and reward the schools
that can get kids out in eight years
it's just too long man but nobody wants to be
in school for 12 years come on man it's terrible
all right so that's one thing the
other thing is i would i would uh
you know i would definitely not this
whole mandating thing's crazy it's insane
i i would i would say look if you don't want
to get vaccinated we're going to send your
two shots to the countries that need it because
there's countries that can't get the vaccines
about 35 of the american public doesn't
want to get the shot so good man donate
pfizer donate my two shots to africa they
need them you guys say you can't get them
quit trying to shove them shove them in my
shoulder send them to people that want them
last question just on cardone capital
we've talked about going into debt
under which scenarios should people who
are considering getting on your deal go
into debt to do so no they should not nobody
should borrow money to to invest in that deal
okay you know what what money should be using
you should borrow money to improve yourself
you should borrow money for your own business
but i would never borrow money for an investment
now that being said if you have equity in your
home you got four or five hundred thousand dollars
worth of equity in your home earning zero you
got two or three hundred thousand sitting in an
ira or 401k or you got 40 000 you're self-directed
like you're you have a self-directed ira or a 401k
i'm sure you have something sitting over
there but you're as a self-employed person
if you have a retirement account or you left
your company years ago and you now have your
retirement account that's self-directed i would
use that money i would borrow against my house
i would borrow against the equity
in my house and invest in that deal
but i wouldn't go i wouldn't go bored
ten thousand dollars on a credit card
uh to invest in that deal
so someone hasn't i would
i would borrow 10 000 on my credit card
to go to an event that taught me how
like i would always tell people yeah dude load
up on your credit card if it makes you better
i would i would i would borrow money for marketing
but i wouldn't borrow money to invest with grant
cardone capital so someone has 10k equity in
their home right now yeah they pulled it out
to invest in cardone capital what am i paying
an interest on my home and what's my how does
that does that math work out yeah yeah yeah it
would work out it would 100 work out and and uh
so i would borrow i would grab ten thousand i i
think i think that that person i you know would
be in a better position to find ten thousand
dollars some other place like just go to your
mom and say hey i'll give you the ten thousand
dollars equity in my house against ten thousand
dollars because there's cash everywhere right now
there there's about 12 trillion dollars sitting
in cash accounts today there's about 12 trillion
sitting in equity in homes it's all dead money
and that's why you see these big groups going
out and buying homes right now the housing market
anybody that thinks there's gonna be a housing
crash you guys are wrong there's no chance of a
housing crash in this country there's a shortage
of housing today there's there's a there's a
there's a uh oversupply of investors buying houses
that have never existed in america in our entire
200 years or however long we've been around
here okay we have investors buying homes now
that are replacing the end user buying a house
there's a shortage of supply there's there's
massive inflation hitting hitting most of
the housing stock materials concrete glass
we're going to get inflation interest rates will
stay at zero otherwise the entire u.s government
will have to go bankrupt we'll we're never going
to see high interest rates in this country again
just because we have too much debt we can't it's
just monopoly now and this will be the safest
asset class i believe for the next 20 years we're
in a super cycle where at the beginnings of it
it will be the place that people should have their
money uh and so like how does somebody make sense
of the ten thousand i think to every ten thousand
ends up being twenty grand in five years maybe
thirty thousand better scenario is i send you back
to 10 000 in five years and you still you're still
an owner with me in the property because i'm going
to refinance the property with new debt send you
back your 10 grand non-taxable event rich people
sell stuff wealthy people never sell anything
buy borrow diet huh buy borrow die yeah exactly
so like like if warren wanted money right now
what worm will never pay taxes okay like the
old man he's the smartest salesman in the world
he would just go borrow against his berkshire
like he'd be like i want to borrow 10 million
again he i mean how could he need he doesn't
need money like ever right he's just going to
go buy another company you know you know that he
his 70 of all his investments are in four stocks
he is he is not he does not do what he tells
everybody else to do which is hey you guys need to
diversify your investments most of his money's in
four different stocks elon's got three stocks jeff
bezos one stock steve jobs had two i love it well
the main is grant cardone the website is cardone
capital we'll link that up down the description
below go check it out grant as always appreciate
you the time the education and looking forward to
more financial content coming up from you man good
the shirt looks great on you bro and and uh the
hoodie looks great on you evan i appreciate you
so much man i gotta tell you yeah i gotta tell you
man when we did uh what was the thing we did with
evan we did a challenge and you were on it bro
you were freaking like that was amazing amazing we
got to figure out how to do that i told you that
then now we just got to figure out how to do it so
i i mean let me know happy to help man okay i
appreciate you brother appreciate everything
you're doing man all right much love thank
you grant thank you brother see you soon if
you want to see the one-on-one i did recently
with grant check it out right there next to me
i think you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i'll tell everybody right
now i didn't hit the target spoiler you got kovitz
yeah they are testing me every week the first week
i test positive i'm calling home every night on
my new phone to my wife crying like a little baby